jehad watch that's a website that tracks
the activities of radical Islam PayPal
kicked jihad watch out said he could no
longer raise money through them why
because leftist groups said jihad watch
showed quote extreme hostility to
Muslims they equated conservative
opinion with hate that was a clip from
me yesterday my editorial at the top of
the I think was the ten o'clock hour
yesterday got a lot of play on the
Internet PayPal by the way has since
been restored I'm sorry
jihad watch has been restored its back
on PayPal joining us now the director of
jihad watch Robert Spencer sir
welcome to the program it's great to
have you with us thank you great to be
here before we go any further
what does jihad watch do jihad watch is
a news and commentary organization
dedicated to explaining what is the
motivating ideology behind jihad terror
what the jihadis are all about what they
think what motivates them what they want
to accomplish that's it that's all we do
and you are kicked off PayPal originally
because you'd shown I think the quote
was you'd shown extreme hostility to
Muslims would you contest that oh
absolutely yes the thing about it is
PayPal just like the other leftist
groups that were behind this notably the
Southern Poverty Law Center they don't
allow any appeal they don't allow you to
dissent to discuss to debate to explain
I don't have any hostility toward anyone
I'm tracking jihad activity which
everyone should oppose including Muslims
who profess to reject it and abhorrent
and so there's no reason for the charge
except that there are groups that have
for years now equated all opposition to
jihad terror with hatred bigotry and
Islamophobia and they were the groups
that PayPal was listening to that was
the point that I was making in the
editorial the conservative opinion is
now banned because it is called hate
speech that's absolutely wrong but
that's what happened in your case I
think you were branded as a hate monger
and therefore suitable for being kicked
off you have no redress of you I know
you're back on PayPal but I think I
think this is go
all over the place in America am i right
oh yeah there's no doubt about it this
is a concerted and organized effort
I have heard about other groups that
track jihad activity that have likewise
been cut off from PayPal and they have
not been restored
also just today I heard from a gentleman
who had a youtube playlist of my videos
videos like my appearances on various
shows or my lectures at various
universities and they flagged the
playlist as inappropriate and removed it
and this is the same kind of thing
that's happening all over there is a
concerted effort to deny a platform to
anyone and everyone who does not espouse
the hard left agenda on that subject I
want to bring up the case of Google and
the fired Google employee James d'amour
he sent that diversity memo as you know
it was leaked his lawyer says other
employees are claiming Google
discriminated against them too after
challenging Google's liberal politics I
think this fits the pattern of
conservative opinion being suppressed
and banned am i right
oh there's no doubt about it whatsoever
as a matter of fact Google recently did
the same thing they there was an imam
from texas omar suleiman who contacted
google and complained that when you
googled things like Islam and jihad you
got material about terrorism which is
entirely reasonable since the terrorists
constantly point to Islamic texts and
teachings to justify what they do and
make recruits among peaceful Muslims but
they listened to Omar Suleiman and now
Google has changed the way it works at
search engines so that when you google
things like jihad Islam Sharia you only
get material about how Islam is a
religion of peace and nothing about how
terrorists use it to justify what
they're doing we just can't let freedom
of speech be impinged upon the way it is
being impinged upon now we just can't
let it happen
you're part of the solution Robert and
we're proud to have you on the show
thanks for joining us thank you he'll be
back all right coming up tropical storm
Harvey